hey guys so what really makes a man more
attractive
and i'm not talking about vanity here
you know these days
the world's getting crazy people are
becoming more arrogant
vain lovers of themselves this is not
what i'm talking about
i'm just talking about looking good as
good as you can be
looking more attractive for that first
date you know or your girlfriend or for
your wife like myself
or for that job interview going to work
looking professional
but what really makes a man more
attractive
yeah we know genes play a role but even
if
you think you don't have the best genes
out there in the world
there are still things that you can do
to improve yourself
to be the best that you can be and
that's what i'm going to talk about
in this video so let's not waste any
more time let's get into it
[Music]
now just very quick if it's the first
time that you're here on my channel
welcome my name is daniel moritz and if
you haven't subscribed yet please
consider it
and also click that notification bell so
you won't miss a thing
now what makes a man more attractive
well a lot of guys especially young guys
out there
think that it's it's that type of guy
who looks good
dresses fancy big brand clothes he's got
a lot of money
drives around in a sports car in a
ferrari or a lamborghini
but is it really true definitely
not that's only what the media wants you
to believe
the movies and tv series that's what
they do
they want to control the way you think
by making you believe
certain things it brainwashes people and
it's not true
look i've been an international male
model for over 13 years traveling to so
many different countries
and i've spent a lot of time with some
of the most beautiful girls in the world
working with them and staying with them
in modeling apartments
and so you get to know them and this is
what most of them
said they don't like a guy who's
arrogant
puffed up a show-off you know that
arrogant
vain guy that pops himself up driving a
fast car
brags about his money and achievements
now of course just to be totally honest
here
they like the car i mean who doesn't
like the car but i don't like the guy
his personality stinks they think he's
just a tool
so what really makes a man more
attractive
well let's start with the first thing
open and friendly body language
look if you just stand arms crossed
super serious face not making eye
contact you're pushing people away
you might think you'll look cool being
all serious and all
but you don't you actually just look
angry to them and you're closed off
and if there's a girl you like you're
making it very hard
for her to get the courage to come and
talk to you and honestly it's your fault
because you don't look like a open
friendly nice guy
remember if someone sees you for the
first time they don't know you
they don't know anything about you
they've got no clue who you are what
your personality is like
they know nothing so they make
assumptions about you
based on what based on your appearance
yes
but also your behavior your body
language
so they look at you from a distance
figuring you out
and if they see that your body language
is open
friendly you look like a nice guy what
are they gonna think
many studies show that men with open and
friendly body postures
look a lot more attractive than other
guys get in shape
look this is something every guy can do
you don't need to become a
bodybuilder huge and buff but just get
fit and healthy not only will you look
better but you will also
feel better and is going to show in the
way that you carry yourself
now of course we know that people differ
in taste right
but studies from ucla and others show
that the majority of
women find men who have lean muscle
a lot more attractive than guys who are
very
skinny or guys who are extremely
buff talking about yourself
turn the focus on them nobody likes a
guy who just
keeps on talking the whole time about
himself it's selfish and some guys
they feel the need to brag about their
money or their achievements
so that i don't know they do it because
they think other people will like them
more for some reason
it's so silly no turn your attention
your focus
on them for example give other people
the compliments they deserve now you
might be thinking what
daniel giving other people compliments
will make them
like me more what well yes
of course if you don't understand it by
now then please
listen carefully people will almost
always
forget the things you said but they will
never
forget how you make them feel
so unconsciously people will find you
more attractive because
of the way you make them feel whenever
they think about you
and that's also the biggest reason why
people don't like
selfish self-absorbed guys or even
negative guys
for that matter they don't like it
because they feel bad around them they
don't want to be around them that
that feeling that they have is terrible
these people
are walking around like poison toxic
and people just want to get away from
them why because they always just talk
about themselves and their own
problems and people don't want to hear
it they're tired of it
so let me ask you a question and be
honest when was the last time
that you gave someone else an honest
compliment
not because you want them to like you
but just because
you thought of them
[Music]
be honest honesty and truth
more precious than gold these days of
all the pretenders out there
just be you be honest be true to who you
are
and then work on improving yourself
because then
you'll be more attractive than most of
the pretenders out there who try to
be someone that they're not man i hate
it when people lie
don't lie or try cheap tricks to try and
impress
people when it comes to silly tricks
please don't be one of those guys that
goes around trying to pick up girls
pretending
you know to be one of these cool guys
using these pickup lines
that's so corny and let me give an
example for example
excuse me do you have a map and then
i'll say like no
right i mean you say um oh
because i need a map because i keep
getting lost in your beautiful eyes
listen the truth is women love a guy
who is confident and humble
who keeps his promises a guy with
integrity a research study in 20
different countries prove
that your personality is a lot more
important to people
than your looks
you gotta care about the way you look
and smell
you have to have enough respect for
yourself to care about the way you
look and smell if you don't then how do
you expect
other people to do it to respect you
this is very basic but there's still a
lot of guys who don't do it
so just clean yourself up a bit get the
haircut that fits in with your face
shape
and get a good basic skincare routine so
that your face
looks nice and clear and then wear the
right clothes
that fits in with your body type and if
you don't know how to do it check out my
channel there's a lot of videos on here
that will help you out
have some manners if you want to stand
out in today's world
all you got to do is be a stand-up guy
with good
manners because in the day and age we
live in
there's so many guys with no manners at
all
so you want to be different you want to
stand out don't go with the rest of the
current
be different be the stand-up guy with
good manners
many studies even in china show the
people who are
kind and honest were rated more
attractive
than other people and remember this you
can easily judge the character of any
man
by the way he treats other people
especially when they
can't do anything for him you see what
i'm saying
talk about your emotions more and no i
don't mean here
talk about everything and just let it
fly all your emotions
no but just open up a little bit more
don't hide it
just tell your girlfriend or your wife a
little bit more
about just how you really feel about
something
how do you expect them to understand if
they don't really know what's going on
even in my culture we thought men are
different from women right you
got to be strong you don't bleed you
don't cry
and you don't talk about your emotions
well yes
we are different from women we are manly
we are men and we are strong but we also
have emotions and if we don't open up
then the woman in your life is not going
to know who you really are
and they will also think that you're
more like a robot you don't really feel
anything you don't feel anything for
them as well
even i struggled with this for a while
not really opening up about
things that happened in my life and most
of you that's been following me here on
the channel for these last few years you
know
there's a lot of things that have
happened in my life i mean i struggle
with money
my brother was killed by a drug dealer
and the second one died in a car crash
now most of you already know my story
and then i became a christian
my life changed i met my wife and she
also helped me to
open up more and to deal with these
issues
not to run away from it because that's
what we sometimes
do you know you're just thinking uh men
don't talk about it i'm just going to
keep it inside but what you're actually
doing is you're running
from it you got to deal with it that's
what i learned
that not dealing with it is actually the
same as just running away from it
it takes more courage to take it head-on
to deal with it and to talk about it
and at the end it made me stronger and
more stable
as well and not just that it also
enabled me to connect with my wife
on a deeper level and our relationship
is a lot stronger right now
studies also show that when men are a
bit more vulnerable
women find them more desirable both
emotionally
and sexually because that is how she
really connects with you
that's how she really starts to
understand who you really are what's
going on
in your heart she can't connect with
someone who's closed off
someone who doesn't have the courage to
deal with their issues
you get what i'm saying now stick around
watch some of my other videos here
and always remember this life is short
so don't waste yours cheers